so earlier this week I sat down with the
Egyptian president and during our
exclusive interview I asked president
el-sisi what he thought of President
Trump and more watch this there are very
distinct differences in the views and
ideologies of say President Obama and
president Trump you were pretty
impressed with President Trump what are
the differences from your perspective
and Collini collinear let me say from
the first time I saw the debates of
President Trump I admired his
personality and I anticipated his
success not only in the elections but in
success in leading the United States me
the same are the opposition's President
Trump is writing history for the world
and for the night States and we should
help him do that but there was a
difference in as much as President Obama
supported the Muslim Brotherhood
supported Mohammed Morsi Donald Trump
does not he does he has a very different
world view have you noticed the distinct
difference in change in how the United
States is now approaching you under the
new president the outcome in the region
without mentioning policies last year's
and what it brought to the region
the reality is taking place in Syria and
Iraq and Yemen and Somalia and Nigeria
and all the consequences on the security
and stability region and worldwide you
said about Donald Trump is a unique
personality and capable of the
impossible I understand your position on
a two-state solution
could there be another Camp David Accord
maybe include Jordan maybe include other
Arab states with Israel just sit a sit
and doesn't any concession by Israel
don't you need a precondition of their
recognition of their right to exist
wouldn't you need secure borders
securable borders for Israel would you
recognize their right to both and Izola
can is I want to say them I always sell
em dings express it at this way peace
does not only need our will and but it
needs also the beliefs the people
themselves as it hands the leadership
doesn't that convinced with peace our
role is to highlight all of these
positive points of peace commitment and
also to give reassurances to accommodate
the concern of the parties concerns with
peace for example I understand it
appreciates that Israelis enough
security concern with respect to their
safety and security I agree with these
concerns there has to be a solution for
a two-state Israeli States Israeli
citizen and the Palestinian citizens our
safety our well-being and security our
preserves and home let me tell you
because for all the people who are
hearing me now I'm one of the region
that I'm saying that if they are able to
bring about this thing to our regionally
but we will usher in a new age for a
turbulent region that has suffered for
years we will be ushering in a new
horizon of interaction and openness you
know I'm talking about 50 Islamic and
Arab countries that will have
embassies with Israel and Israel
lubricating possess there will be open
borders when I say to prison Trump you
will have an opportunity and to solve
the issue of the century this is the
issue of the century and this is one of
the major pretext of terrorism when we
come back an important reminder as
Hannity continues